what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in let's get
started also guys before I start make
sure you get yourself a women shouldn't
vote t-shirt today they will be
delivered at the end of this month so
make sure you sign up and get your
T-shirt today day the first clip was um
something that I saw I think it's was on
YouTube shorts or Tik Tok or something
and it was a video of Andrew claven from
the daily wire talking about marriage
and as I've said the men from the daily
wire are very out of touch on this issue
they have no idea what is going on in
the dating market today and while I am
happy for them that they don't have to
deal with this craziness um it's funny
because they'll call me out of touch and
say I don't know what I'm talking about
yet none of them have participated in
the dating Market in decades literally
decades me on the other hand I've
interviewed thousands of people that
have given me their opinions on dating
and relationships I I think a lot of
times while they mean well they go into
marriage very naive so I want to pull
this clip that I saw of Andrew let's
what would you consider a prenup prenups
are regularly thrown out all the time
they're typically non- enforceable
especially the longer the marriage goes
on the less likely they are to be
enforced men get absolutely destroyed in
marriage and in divorce 50% of marriages
end in divorce 80% of divorces are
initiated by women 90% if she's college
educated 90% of child support payments
go from men to women 97% of alimony
payments go from men to women you know
you have no fault to divorce so a woman
can cheat on you she can still get half
your [__] first of all it's 40% of first
marriages so 50% the 50% thing you'd
have to add people who get serially
divorced and you shouldn't marry one of
those so that's not a good argument for
not getting married it's a good argument
for not marrying somebody you're going
to have to divorce the way to do that
makees sure she's a conservative goes to
church and is a virgin then you're not
going to get divorced you'll be fine
okay so all right a couple things I like
how he's fighting for this 10% he's like
guys guys guys you guys are doomers it's
not
50% it's 40% of first marriages and I
want to talk about a couple things that
he really I would argue has not
considered so one thing that he has not
considered is that the stats today
include the people that are over the age
of 30 40 50 and 60 and I don't really
think he takes into account how much
social media has influenced the culture
and women in particular so I've said
this before and I'll say it again I
believe that attention to women is the
same thing as sex to men you know and
how I came to this conclusion is if you
ask women if you could be beautiful the
rest of your life you could look 22 the
rest of your life but you would never
sleep with anyone again most women would
pick the beauty over getting to sleep
with
someone um I don't know say Jason mimoa
or whoever it is right where men on the
other hand wouldn't pick the looks they
typically would pick sleeping with the
hot chicks which it it shows us
something that we intrinsically Desire
with women desire to be desired where
men desire to you know have a lot of a
lot of hot chicks you know what I mean
we we value different things there's a
reason that men brag about the women
they've slept with and women don't
there's a reason that women will brag
about the men that have dm'd them or
given them attention at one point or
another where so they're completely
different things now you have to take
into account even the young Christian
virgin chick likely has had access to
social media from a young age so he
hasn't really taken into account how one
the women from 12 years old have had
excess social media and sometimes even
younger in this new generation like um I
think I was talking to Christine she
said for her like they got smartphones
around nine 9 years old that is so young
that completely changes your brain so I
would argue that it's actually going to
be much more grim and it also doesn't
take into account the people didn't get
legally married and just did the
long-term liveing relationship thing and
then ended up getting divorced or
breaking up whatever the other thing
that I don't think he really takes into
account is female nature I'm sorry but
women always have leverage in
relationships in 2023 and there is no
evidence that suggests that women do the
right thing when they get leveraged
we're more prone to violence when we get
leverag we've passed a bunch of
discriminatory policies and he just says
go find a virgin chick and I actually
don't even necessarily disagree with
them I mean that is the best odds for
success but I'm sorry Andrew I have I
get messages every day from guys that
married the Virgin chick that did the
exact same thing and the issue is you
cannot control the culture women we tend
to go with what's trendy um there's a
reason we we get the latest fashion
trends like one year you'll see like
these puffy sleeves one year you'll see
women will have literal holes in their
sleeves big holes in jeans and you think
why do women do that well we always do
what's cool we always do what's trendy
it's why we have the duck lips now the
Botox forehead all this nonsense even
the virgins of today are not the virgins
of yesterday because the problem is when
you when there is a unicorn the line
that piles up for that unicorn changes
the woman most women do not do the right
thing and they go crazy when they get
excess attention you can see examples of
this where wholesome women like when
Miley Cyrus she was kind of a wholesome
chick from the
Midwest and then she goes crazy Britney
Spear is another one all of these chicks
that get excessive attention from a
young age go crazy they go insane women
are not meant to do that and so the
issue is Andrew says basically find a
unicorn well Andrew only 4% of women
wait till they're married that's not
enough to go around that would still
leave a large portion of
men W without a wife to pick from and
what I'm saying is actually biblical
because it says in the Bible that men
are better to live alone than with a
quarrelsome wife well what if all of the
women on the market are
quarrelsome and the other thing is most
women have never been taught what it
means to be a wife most women have never
been taught about submission most women
have never been taught these things
so Andrew is basically saying just find
a
unicorn and find a girl that prays and
therefore you will have great odds um he
then says 40% chance um and even the
other thing
is I want to say I can't remember it off
the top of my head but it was roughly
like 40% of people that get divorced are
religious and then this is like the The
Comeback you'll always
see they're not real religious they're
not the real Catholics they're the real
Christians and then it gets into a funny
place where we're kind of playing God
who are you to decide who is the real
Christians and real Catholics I mean are
you without sin I'm not without sin how
how do you know um the only thing you
can really do is ask people and
obviously maybe you say let's say 10% or
20% aren't real even if it's a 20%
chance of divorce divor you know that's
a 20% chance of living hell for a guy I
mean I think I think it's pretty much
hell to a guy to have to watch another
man raise his kids and that is the
situation a lot of men are in where a
stranger is going to have more of an
influence and an impact on his children
than he will okay so the comment section
had a lot to say um the old dude said it
so casually like we are still in his era
um blood 4939 says conservative that
goes to church and is a virgin like that
is so easy in this era yes and Andrew I
have interviewed thousands of people
thousands like literally I've been
interviewing people on the streets in
person for
years do you know how many virgin chicks
I've met that I actually believe because
you know you also get the ones that say
they are but are super
argumentative and disagreeable so you
know a virgin isn't even uh a a spiteful
virgin isn't even ideal 4% of women are
virgins on their wedding
days that still accounts for the
argumentative virgins the fat virgins
this isn't what men want okay but
anyways out of thousands of interviews
you know how many I found one one and
you can't even tell me that we're
picking for special chicks no Andrew no
Andrew this is the culture this is the
new world more there are more only fans
models than teachers now